[Music]
hello and welcome to my presentation i'm
super super thrilled to be talking to
you today about my favorite topic and
that is code reviews my presentation is
called from bottleneck to superpower and
it's a presentation about all the
findings that i collected and the
research results that i that i got from
the last 10 or even more years of
researching and working with teams on
their code review practices so
i was for quite some time at microsoft
and i was
i was
responsible for analyzing the code
review processes at microsoft and
helping teams adopt better better
practices we also owned the code review
tool the internal code review tool code
flow at that time and so this is how i
came in contact with code reviews and
over the last years i i really got very
fascinated by this topic and i did more
and more studies in that area but also i
worked more and more with teams not only
at microsoft but around the world on the
code review practices and today i'm
gonna share with you how you can
actually improve your productivity
while doing code reviews and what
problems we actually have during code
reviews with productivity so i'm super
thrilled to dive in with you in this
really fascinating topic for me and if
you want to find more about my wig go to
awesomecoderviews.com
but now let's go into that
if you look at code reviews we see that
code reviews offer a large variety of
benefits it starts from well you get
more readable and more maintainable code
at least that's what we hope you get
improved solutions you have an accident
prevention mechanism with code review
maybe you find bugs
there is tracing and tracking which
means that you can go back and really
understand why a certain solution has
been implemented in a certain way there
is also learning and mentoring happening
in code reviews and knowledge sharing so
plenty of reasons why people want to do
code reviews the question is is that
actually true are we are we setting out
to do that but do we actually get those
benefits and there are a couple of
studies
that actually show that we are getting
those benefits out right there are
studies on
how code reviews correlate with the
reduction of defects in post release and
pre-release software so before we
release it and after
we see that for example unreviewed code
is two times more likely to introduce
defects than reviewed code there are
also studies this is a newer study by
done by google or at google and it shows
that 80
of the code reviews lead to code
improvements so yeah right that's good
and there are also findings around
knowledge sharing for example by rigby
which shows that
code review really increases the
knowledge of a team member about the
code base right so more people are aware
what's going on more people have really
knowledge about the code base so all of
these good things are really happening
in code reviews
and so it's no surprise that when
the pull request development model which
was introduced a couple of years ago
a lot of people actually hopped on the
code review wagon but i don't think it
was extremely deliberate so it was more
than the source control versioning
system suddenly had a feature that we
are using well a pull request right and
so while we are doing a pull request
instead of pushing the code over
somebody has to pull it in and if these
are two people what are they naturally
doing they're looking at the code
exactly because they don't want to pull
something in that they have no idea what
it is somehow it's their responsibility
and so in this
in this
change that happened here in the way how
we're developing software we saw that
suddenly people are adopting uh code
reviews right and very often nowadays
code reviews are actually used
synonymously with pull requests even
though it's not the same thing right the
pull request is not a code review you
can't have a code review without pull
requests and a pull request without code
reviews but very often it's used
at the same time and this is why we also
see it as
something
similar right
and so now all these companies having
these code
reviews and this pull request or pull
based development model and they think
well we will be so happy
our developers will just learn they will
strive they will the code base will
improve and and everything is great
everything is great
but actually that's not what happened
right while i love code reviews
a lot of people don't love code reviews
while they are very widely adopted
they're also creating a lot of problems
and here are just a few of them i've
been working with so many teams and it
doesn't matter how serious they are
about code reviews or how how eager they
are to make them work
still they are
experiencing some of those pain points
that i have listed here and this is
really just a small
um a small subset of all the pain points
but they're dealing with large reviews
what happens well now it's difficult to
review it i don't understand the context
here
they maybe have to wait for their code
reviews
to be to be done by by the engineers
maybe there is time pressure maybe there
is low rewards or almost no rewards
going on
maybe you have a low feedback quality
performance pressure
social things like bullying conflicts
feeling attacked so all of that happens
in code reviews that's the brutal honest
truth
and so we have to weigh
the benefits that we have with these
pain points the good news is that i've
been working with a lot of teams over
the years and these pain points can
actually be worked on so you can remove
those pain points and you can really get
to a very very beneficial practice where
all of your engineers say i never want
to work in a team without code reviews
anymore right so you can reduce the pain
points if you're deliberately working on
them and you can increase the benefits
and so how do you have to do that well
you have to first of all not just accept
that well there is a feature we are
using it and now everything will work
out of the box
code reviews are actually a
socio-technical engineering practice
this means that you have to have really
good social skills and you have to have
really good technical skills and if you
think back about let's let's think about
testing as an engineering practice who
would assume that an engineer starts
testing
automated tests writing automated test
integration test without ever having
read anything or learned anything about
testing
that's not something that we would
assume but code reviews are actually
even more complex because you have the
socio and technical
engineering practice right so testing
you just have to deal with yourself in
the code now you have to deal with your
peers and the code
and then there's actually an another
layer which makes the code reviews so
painful and so difficult and that's the
organizational skills that you have to
do because it's not only you writing the
code it's also somebody else you know
reviewing their code they have to have
time they have to be willing to be
to look at that and as an organization
you have to decide
how are we doing code reviews what do we
want to get out of code reviews right so
we have the
social side we have the technical side
and we have the organizational skills
and it's actually for me really wild
that people are not thinking about how
can we learn that how can we train our
engineers how can we learn as a group as
an organization as a team
and so this is uh why i think it's so
important to think about code reviews
and really how can we do them in a
better way
so when i was working with teams and i
saw this huge list of pain points that
they are experiencing i was thinking
like where's the root cause right so
where should we start should we start
working on you know the social
interactions should we start working on
um the the low feedback quality
and when i analyzed it over and over
again i saw actually that there are two
patterns two main pain points that um
teams experience and if you work on
those two you can actually improve a lot
of the others right so they are all
falling into place and this is slow
turnaround time and low code ref
feedback quality right so either it
takes really a lot of time
or the quality is really really low
and funnily it's not either or it's even
that it can be combined right so some of
the teams and this is what i call the
code review quadrant and that would like
to have people really reflect on that
and think about where are we in in as an
as a team uh in our cultural practice
right do we have like
high review speed but low review quality
right so a lot of looks good to me
within a few hours or even minutes or do
we have like maybe
a high feedback quality right so
thorough reviews but it takes really a
lot of time
or are we even in a blocking state where
we have like slow
reviews and low feedback quality right
so i'm getting look looks good to me
or something like that or some
nitpicking but i have to wait wait in a
week for that
and i think where every team wants to be
is in this power review
area right in this quadrant place here
where you have thorough reviews you get
really good review feedback back um but
the reviews are also delivered in a very
timely manner and so when i'm working
with teams i really try
to get them into that place right so
that we are improving the feedback
quality and the review speed today
because this whole conference is about
productivity i will mostly talk about
speed and how can we speed up
and so but for that i want to do some
mental exercise with you right so a
little bit of brainstorming
if i say i want to increase the review
speed
what do you think happens with feedback
quality can we increase both because
that's what i'm actually promising in my
career workshops can we increase the
speed and the feedback value at the same
time or is it is this impossible
maybe we think something like this
happens if we increase the speed
we actually decrease the feedback value
well i'm writing a code real book let's
say i tell you
please review my first chapter it has 30
pages and i give you five minutes
what will happen
what kind of feedback can you give me
well it's a very different kind of
feedback than if i give you a whole day
to review those 30 pages and very
similar we see that in code reviews
that if you think about really this
reviewer perspective well one person in
front of their of their code review if
you're increasing the speed you're
decreasing the review value right
obviously there's a certain point where
it's okay but if you don't have enough
time you cannot give a very quality
thorough review and there are studies
around this this is a study from cisco
systems for example where we see that
the defect detection rate right so how
many defects per thousand lines of code
are people finding
versus how many lines of code they have
to review within an hour and you see
that around 200 it starts to drop right
and so from this study there's actually
this guideline that you should have like
200 to 400 lines per code max and
nowadays these uh
the suggestions are even lower right
less than 200 lines of code would be
better having 100 lines of code and so
um so there's a correlation
some relationship between the speed and
the value
i'm not going to go more deep into that
but you can actually increase both
and where whereas the easiest to do that
is with the process speed because
reviewing as i said is not only an
individual practice it's a team practice
and so suddenly it's not only how long
does that person take when they're in
front of the review looking through your
code right let's say you sent them 400
lines of code it doesn't really matter
if they take an hour or one and a half
that's that's not the real cost that you
have in code reviews the real cost that
you have is that that person needs to
have time to look at the code review and
that could be four hours and maybe
there's another person even on the code
review because you need two sums up and
so that person needs six hours until
they can get to the code review maybe
there is like a time time zone
difference or whatnot
and then it doesn't matter if one needs
45 minutes in the other hour right so
this is the smaller cost the really
inexpensive cost are the process costs
around and what i see over and over
again and there are many studies also
around that is that if you have like the
process speed if you
increase that you make that faster more
smooth then you're increasing the speed
back
feedback
their review value
and i want to give you a small example
for that let's just
let's just imagine that i'm sending you
the same feedback today
versus a week later even though it's the
same feedback today it will be
more important more valuable to you than
if i send it to you in a week right
and so
this is just to to summarize the problem
that we are seeing and this is a person
that states the problem is that there
can be a lot of lag between asking
someone to review the pr and them
actually doing it or between addressing
comments and then making another look
right worst of all you never really know
how long things will take so it's hard
to know whether you should switch gears
for the rest of the day or not right so
this is i think a good very personal and
very individual perspective on the
problem you can have obviously also an
organizational perspective but this is
an individual perspective and a lot of
people i think feel these pain points
and so
one rule of
thumb but really a good rule is that if
you're in the middle of a focused task
such as writing code don't interrupt
yourself to do a code review right so
the words that you can have is like some
pull requests reminders code review
reminders popping up while you're doing
something very productive while you're
in a deep work phase and then you're
going to do a code review that's
actually horrible practice right
so we don't want that and
there are also a lot of studies isn't
actually a study done by microsoft
around
interruptions during developer time
right people writing code and we see
that it increases task completion time
so it takes longer it makes you make
worse decisions it leads to more errors
frustration annoyance and anxiety so no
no no we don't want that
there are also other studies that show
that even two seconds of interruptions
caused a lot of more mistakes and and a
lot of delay
so what can we do instead of like
hopping over to the code review what can
we do well there are a couple of really
best practices that we can extract out
this was a study that i've been doing at
microsoft and we could really generalize
a couple of those things so we say
independent of the practices of the
teams because
code reviews at microsoft are very
diverse right teams have different
practices that they have those are
common strategies that really are
helpful to speed up the code review and
improve the value well first of all self
review so instead of sending code out
you do the review yourself maybe you
have even a checklist there
you see the divs and probably you
experienced that yourself that you had
you were writing a feature and you
actually forgot that you did this and
that and changed something over there as
well and only when you're creating a
pull request you suddenly see it again
right that's also called the expert
blind spot you get very um very
familiarized with your own code changes
so looking at that and really making
sure this is high quality code the
highest quality code that i can produce
before sending it to somebody else right
so really small management cost here
then having small reviews and i will
talk a little bit more about this so
important coherent code changes that
you'd really make sense and we'll talk
about this as well
context write those code view
descriptions i know nobody does it but
there's plenty of of research that also
shows that it's really important
i've done one and we saw that the
effect is really tremendous
training it's so important that people
know what to look for in code reviews
how to do a code reviews that you have
set up right rules that people are not
um wasting time on deciding whether or
not they should comment on that then
maybe they are arguing in code reviews
about something but really have a
training and have some education around
that that people know
what to expect and how to do that
then run the test first you run the test
first and then you send it for code
reviews have automation in place
whatever automation can do people don't
have to do and that's
two thumbs up if i you know if i have
more hands i would have more hands up
automation is really important so it
could be study analysis linters style
checkers and a lot of other things so
what you can automate please automate it
so that people don't have to do it
and then have the right tools around
it's the int right there could be risk
assessment and that goes a little bit
back to training again that people
actually know what's the risk associated
with this change and depending on that
you actually assign the right reviewers
and then it's crystal clear uh
guidelines and policies that really
reflect your goals because only then
you're actually doing something very
productive here
but there are other things also and a
lot of those things has to do who should
be on the review when should they do the
review right how many reviews and so on
and there are some strategies that you
can actually have that are beneficial
like time blocks that you say well
developers start actually the day or end
the day with some code review so it
could be in the middle depending on the
time zones that you have also
to serve right there could be rotations
a developer takes over a code review per
day or per week right there could be
behavioral mechanisms that you say well
whenever you're sending out a code
review you're asking for a code you you
do one in return and there are also
algorithms that can help you like round
rubbing or load balancing algorithms and
tools that help you to actually assign
it automatically but you have to be
aware that your your strategy here has
to reflect your goals right finding
defects improvements awareness mentoring
and teaching tracing and tracking right
if i want to find defects i definitely
have to have a person that's more
experienced and the best is a person
that has seen this code before we have
seen that in studies
if you want to have mentoring and
teaching maybe you want a junior
engineer here and now we're coming back
to the risk well then some automatic
approaches where you have like a round
robin are not the best because a high a
high change high risk change for example
shouldn't be assigned to a junior
engineer
so it's a little bit more complicated
here but what you can definitely do is
you can work on smaller reviews that's
so important right small and curious
changes and how you do that well with
feature flagging so you're working on
smaller things and you just push that
out
in production even right
while you're still developing it it also
means that your heavy branching and
using git to really make sure that
you're reviewing smaller code things
so this is the study also from cisco
where we see the correlation between
logs lines of code under review and time
and you see that there is a correlation
right it goes down and it's not the same
as before because here it doesn't matter
how long time how long do people have
time so you can give them two hours a
day
we still see that they're not finding
the defects if there are so many things
and we did a similar study at microsoft
and here you see not the lines of code
but the number of files in the change
set and you see it goes down right so
the percentage of useful comments
decreases drastically with the number of
files in the change set
so you want
independent and self-contained
code changes and this is a little bit
tricky but let's have a toy example
let's say you're working on a feature
and while you're in
the first file right you see some
something and you you know enact the boy
scout rule and you say well i'm renaming
this here it's a refactoring and then
you see a fix right you have to fix
something because you revealed it back
while doing this feature and so you're
actually going to other
files and you're doing things here
well now you're sending this out because
it's triple to you right it's called the
expert blind spot again right so it's
really trivial to you but it's actually
hard for the others to understand it
would be much better if this you know
would be extracted in one pull request
or in one code review and then a fix
would be in one code and the feature in
one because then you have coherent
a coherent file or change set and it's
more easy for the other person to
understand and understanding code
comprehension is really tricky in code
reviews right so you want actually to do
that and you could can use for example
this is just one approach there are many
many approaches but this is one approach
you could have like review branches for
that right so instead of committing
everything on one working progress pull
request and then have this
request
and people could also use like commit
based reviews uh but it's also nice if
you have like
each of those steps as a
separate branch which is on top of the
other branch which also means you can
send it out for review and can work
further and then you send it out for
review and work further and it's really
better for code comprehension to do it
that way
well this brings me somehow to the end i
know it was very short i was given 20
minutes so i tried to put as much
information as i could in there and i
really focused on the productivity part
here so really small coherent changes
are the key and there are a lot of
techniques that you can actually do to
do that um it takes a little bit of
training it takes a little bit of um
practicing a little bit of muscle memory
right a little bit like the single
responsibility principle also not comes
to you you have to actually learn it and
apply it
but then i think it's very very powerful
and you have to think about how to how
do we organize that that it's actually
fitting our goals right how are we going
to do code reviews as a collective as a
team so that nobody actually suffers you
know one has this pile of reviews and
the other does nothing um or you're
waiting too long
in general code reviews if you work on
your communication skills so important
knowing what to look for in code two is
really really important reducing review
burden is also very important also to
speed up code reviews
clear guidelines and policies very
important to speed them up and as i said
education and training if you have brown
bags around that really make code
reviews a topic that is discussed and
treated with respect
and deliberately
improved in your organization i think
this is very very important
so if you want
you can follow me on twitter and now i
think it's time for questions and the
discussion there is also a free ebook if
you want to download that and feel free
to reach out to me thank you so much for
listening to my talk